what do you think i did
say it
if you did hurt him
on purpose
you can tell me
hey guys pete here this will be my
dexter new blood episode 5 breakdown i'm
going to recap everything that happened
in runaway and there was a lot and then
i'll let you know what i think about how
things are coming together the fifth
episode worked as a nice follow-up that
managed to crank things up another notch
and in the process brought back a
beloved character there's a lot to get
into so just a quick spoiler warning if
you're not caught up with new blood
through episode 5 then this video won't
be for you and with that out of the way
let's get into it the episode opens with
dexter home alone looking at the
straight razor and wondering what to do
about it he's going back and forth a lot
and we see this through deb he thinks
about whether he could have remembered
what happened to rita as in going
through it obviously he knows what
happened to his mother but dexter's
wondering if the experience created a
dark passenger the same way it did for
him deb reinforces that and she's
advocating for helping him the right way
because what harry did to him teaching
him to be a serial killer who can get
away with it that was child abuse and
from there he goes through all of the
options he knows it can be lonely so
he's able to talk himself into thinking
that this is all really about helping a
son it just happens to have that added
bonus of him getting to unburden himself
and have that connection with someone
else that accepts him as he is the debt
side of things tries to guide him back
towards reality and kind of underlines
that side of the argument by saying what
are you gonna do tell him that there are
a hundred garbage bags of chopped up
human beings at the bottom of the
atlantic ocean what do you think that
would do to him he turned out worse than
you and you're a [ __ ] monster when
harrison comes home he's actually in
high spirits after the assembly and
dexter's waiting to confront him about
the razor at first he's upset that he
looked through his things but then he
says that he only carries it for
protection dexter asks him why he took
it to school because he's trying to find
this open so that he can talk to him
about what's going on and not
unsurprisingly his son gets defensive
about the question especially the
reference to him hearing ethan's story
saying you believe some psycho school
shooter over me dex pleads that he just
wants to know the truth he's not judging
him if he did hurt ethan on purpose then
he can tell his father he just thinks
he's a kid that's going through
something that he doesn't understand and
he wants to help him and he caps it off
saying harrison you can trust me and
fittingly his son says why the [ __ ]
would i trust you you're the one living
a lie jim and he's got a point then he
goes outside to cool off and zach and
scott show up out of the blue and they
want to take him to a party he finds out
it's a kill list party so everyone
inside thinks that they're alive because
of him which is a pretty good place to
be in at a party he talks to audrey she
asks if he doesn't text her back so much
anymore because of the podcast and it's
interesting because he asked her
directly how they got the picture of
ethan's list which she lets on that she
took at the police station from there he
starts to get wasted a girl comes up and
gives him an ecstasy pill and he starts
to spiral a bit and then later we see
scott give him something and after he
takes it audrey notices that he's not
doing well and then he throws it out
there that his father doesn't believe
him and he says that his dad's the liar
and that jim lindsey isn't even his real
name and then he passes out she has to
call 9-1-1 logan arrives to administer
narcan and realizes that it was scott
that gave him the drug so he threatens
to arrest him if he doesn't give up his
dealer dexter gets called to the
hospital where he finds out harrison od
but is okay it turns out he had black
market pills that looked like oxycontin
but were really fentanyl he learns from
logan that they came from a guy named
miles who is selling fake pills out of a
dive bar in moose creek and then they
end up having words after logan tells
him that harrison needs tough love he
says you think being the assistant
wrestling coach makes you a parenting
expert and then on the way out deb tells
him that it's all his fault
at home he's on the way out he asked if
harrison will be all right by himself
and reminds him that his first
appointment with his therapist is this
afternoon then he tries to reassure him
by saying that we're gonna get through
this after he leaves harrison throws
away his breakfast without eating it
including the plate dexter is on a
mission to kill miles he goes to a shed
and grabs a box of trash bags he stops
by at the vet to get syringes and
ketamine and then goes looking for the
dealer he finds him at the bar he makes
an introduction as a buyer he gets him
outside and then he's about to knock him
out when the cops show up at the exact
same time he starts beating him up
instead to cover up what was actually
happening and then logan tells him he
needs to follow them to the police
station to fill out some forms while
he's there he's trying to get
information as logan is questioning
miles he does some really effective
intimidation and gets the guy to name
the person who makes the pills and
dexter manages to get the name and
address he goes there and cases his
house and deb tries to talk him into
leaving she says go home to harrison
work on being a good dad she says she's
never seen him like this before it's not
about the code or feeding your urges
it's about vengeance and this seems true
it's impulsive but he's also telling
himself that he's trying to do it for
harrison he's able to sneak into the
house he gets the syringe ready and
while he's looking around he finds the
room where he makes the pills for proof
then he sneaks up on him hits him with
the shot and puts together a kill room
he wakes him up and talks to him about
the people that he killed and it turns
out jasper is a piece of work everything
he says reinforces this idea that dexter
has that he's been alive for long enough
once again though he is interrupted when
logan pulls up outside so he has to
change his kill instead of stabbing him
and disposing of the body he has to give
him drugs make it look like an od and
then leave him in the pill room where
the cops discover him and he's not the
only serial killer operating in the area
at the cabin we get a better idea about
kurtzemo when he brings chloe into the
basement room he tells her that she can
stay as long as she likes the meals are
for free and when she asks can you
actually be this nice he tells her that
he's been lucky in life to have more
than he needs he just humbly asks that
she pays it forward eventually she
realizes she's locked in she discovers
the camera just like lily did and things
are underway kirk goes over to the
tavern and starts putting money in the
jukebox and we learn from tess that he
does this every couple of months he
comes in acts like he owns the place he
plays runaway looking somewhat crazed
while he's listening and starts dancing
then he asks her to dance with him and
it seems like this is something that
goes along with his kill cycle later as
he's watching her on his laptop she
starts to try to offer him sex as a way
to get out and he quickly asks her to
stop it saying it's not what this is
about when she continues and starts to
take off her bra he slams the laptop
closed as if that ruins what he's
getting out of this later he has the
hunting gear on and then he buzzes open
the door and tells her that she's free
to go she stops at the door and looks at
the camera and says make me we saw that
she had a broken piece of mirror so now
she's trying to get him to come into the
room where she can slash him and she is
able to do that but it's not very
effective he ends up dragging her
outside where she still won't run away
eventually she charges him and in
frustration he has to shoot her that way
which really pisses him off in his eyes
she's ruined everything
angela and molly decided to take a trip
to new york when they learned that
matt's credit cards were used at a hotel
in the city when they get there she's
able to use her badge to persuade the
desk clerk to tell them that matt
checked out she wants to see the camera
footage to confirm it's him and after
some convincing he says that he'll have
the it guys pull the footage and that
she can come back that night and when
they do come back and do that they
realize that it was someone else
pretending to be him which makes it seem
likely that kurt paid this person to use
his cards to make it look like he was
there and i'm sure that they'll be
asking him about it when they return to
iron lake but that's not really the big
thing that happens while they're in new
york the other reason that angela
decided to go was because there was this
law enforcement missing persons
conference going on and when they go
into the first lecture it's angel
batista from the miami pd and he brings
up the bay harbor butcher case molly
brings up that she's done an episode
about him and if you didn't listen to it
they did put out one episode of her
podcast as an extra after h's for hero
and in that she does reference the bay
harbour butcher and the ice truck killer
but she tells angela how they thought it
was actually a cop at the department and
can you imagine being right next to a
serial killer for like years and having
no idea which of course she can and is
angel talks about how they found the
common connection with all his victims
and that they all committed crimes they
got away with when you find that it may
turn out that one person is responsible
for all the disappearances angela thinks
this makes sense in relation to her case
and so she goes to talk to him at the
bar she gives him background on what's
going on and he essentially tells her
that she just has to trust her gut he
does take a swing he tries to hit on her
and she brings up her boyfriend and it
is a pretty funny exchange where he asks
if he can handle you and she says that
he chops his own wood and then angels
saying he wouldn't want to end up on the
wrong end of an axe and talking about
sticking to your gut he brings up deb
and the trinity case and it comes out
that she died and her brother died too
it was all tragic and that he left a son
behind which he can't think of his name
at first but as he's walking away he
says harrison and you see that it does
get the wheels turning in her head which
i suppose is supposed to indicate that
she's putting it together from
harrison's last name of harrison morgan
i'm not sure if that's ever been
confirmed on screen that that's what
they know him as but i don't see how we
get where we get if that's not the case
speaking of harrison he's been out
walking around he's come to the
conclusion that he's going to leave town
and he runs into kurt who offers to buy
him a meal as they're going into the
truck stop he notices the cut on kurt's
cheek and he explains that he got it in
a hunting accident they talk and he
gives them some advice essentially when
you're angry at someone you go and do
something kind for them and harrison is
not into the idea at first it seems like
he's made up his mind about dexter but
then kurt offers him a job gives him an
application and when harrison asks him
why he's being so nice to him he says
that he has potential he can see it and
just pay it forward so there's the echo
of that there which i guess is there to
make you think that maybe he's gonna be
one of his victims but it doesn't seem
to me that he fits his mo at all and we
saw in this episode that he's very
specific about how that all goes down
things come to a close as angela comes
home and while she's talking to audrey
she finds out that harrison told her
something weird right before he passed
out he told her that his dad's name
wasn't jim lindsey and again we see
angela with the wheels turning inside of
her head then she goes to the station
starts looking things up on the computer
and we see that she prints out the
obituary of dexter morgan and it does
have a picture of his face we don't get
to see what she does with it because the
episode ends there
so this was another solid episode
another intense kind of cliffhanger
ending and it's pretty hard to say where
things go from here it's classic early
season dexter where it seems like he's
caught and there's a recipe for mounting
tension it is what worked best for the
clyde phillips seasons there were a lot
of things in this episode that felt like
clues or at least things that were
supposed to stand out that we would
remember later harrison's interest in
the kill list him seeing the cut on
kurt's face the tension between jim and
logan which has kind of been building up
a bit but really reached a different
level in this episode and just how much
knowledge molly has on serial killers in
case you didn't pick up on that i
thought the buddy trip thing worked
pretty well with those two characters
they kind of split everyone up in this
episode and i thought they worked pretty
good together obviously it was nice to
see angel make an appearance and i have
to say i was rolling my eyes when he
couldn't remember harrison's name like
if they were gonna leave it there that
would have been terrible so i was
actually pretty happy that they wrapped
that all up that she now knows that her
boyfriend is dexter morgan and i really
don't know how that's gonna play out the
kill of the week was okay it's
interesting to see him struggle through
his decisions with deb there as his
counterweight i don't think that new
blood needs to rely on kills of the week
necessarily but this one showed us how
quickly he falls into his old ways and
that aspect of the show can be fun plus
there's a parallel with harrison at the
party too they both fell off the wagon
more or less and are able to jump right
back in at full speed but there are
inherent risks from their stepping away
harrison had immediate consequences and
dexter had multiple close calls now we
know absolutely that kurt is the other
serial killer in town he's definitely
responsible for some if not all of the
girls on angela's board and you gotta
imagine for iris too he is absolutely
cold-blooded he shot chloe in the face
straight in the face in the most
remorseless way possible he was more
upset that it wasted his chance to do
his thing than he was about taking her
life that's for sure his kill cycle is
pretty weird and pretty specific and i
wonder now if he's going to have to
speed things up to find somebody else to
take chloe's place because the cycle was
interrupted i'm curious as to where pay
it forward came from and like i said
before i don't think that harrison's at
any risk of being one of his victims not
from what we've seen so far but it does
seem like kurt is putting out some
effort to get close to harrison so we'll
see where that goes and i think that's a
good place to leave things i'll be doing
a follow-up video in a couple of days
again this week so let me know in the
comments what questions you have what
theories you're running with and i'll
break down the teaser and discuss those
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and thanks for watching
i'll talk to you soon